shake it shake it out shake off shake it
shake punch murder murder your teammate
have y'all played charades before last
race I was maybe 16 years old
what yeah it's what have you been doing
the last not playing charades I don't
think I've ever played it properly
before I tried like two weeks ago
and someone was like that's not how you
do it your dessert always lets go yeah
this is Mary and I'm Eric and we're
Dramamine cuz we're so sick bro yeah
yeah you got that this is Jonah I'm
Tommy and we are a hint of mime third
words love heart love love first word
crazy crazy in love yeah oh yes thank
you for good mm-hmm it's a word film
mummy ghost wants to a dinosaur
Jurassic Park one word person uh-huh oh
is it Dorothy from The Wizard of Oz
knows what girl movie Oh TV show TV show
hittin psycho slashing Zorro no wish it
make your wand isn't a wand Harry Potter
1 2 3 4 words at so many words Game of
Thrones The Game of Thrones Dracula
count vampire a vampire stabbing
movie two words
second word explosion blow up
mmm Wow pop what first word okay
hiking man soldier little-little is the
boy
cheers boy captain bang I don't with the
salute my shorts dynamite Harry Potter
Hermione
I didn't realize that we were included
in the prop table movie four words
fourth word wind gone with the wind
yeah song it's getting hot in here yeah
Nelly baby Oh song one word umbrella
[Music]
Phung don't stop believe and pick it up
I drop oops I dropped it it'll send it
again TV show it's a couple how many
words is that one word love boy
girlfriend boyfriend sounds like been
friends two words
[Music]
cake fudge chocolate
[Music]
two words passwords inspector Forrest
Gump
why does chocolate come in five words
first word orange is the new black
[Music]
character Smeagol Gollum happy Crawley
is it an animal
two words Lion King The Lion King first
word crawl happy control you it's not
you it is you it's not who you are
scooby-doo I've never watched it
scooby-doo a TV show
one word sounds like shoes heels shoes
shoes scuff shine shoeshine okay second
syllable second word I don't know it's
just me
first of all character person monopoly
man monopoly odd wrinkled milkshake that
guy I'm sure Gilbert Grape monocle who
has a monocle ZF monocle - monocles
that's glasses two words one monocle the
monocle man monocle lady Charlotte close
o monocle I think so no same thing
two words Rudo antlers horns I don't
know what your dude is this a person you
were not specific it's a person it's
character okay you've got horns here is
it like goal a golem is it like a Mickey
Mouse we got it we got it if we just got
making outs or whatever really
embarrassed some there's a whole routine
two words disco fever disco do the
Hustle that's four words up Macarena
song
you're shaking shake it out shake off
shake it shake punch murder murder I'm
dancing queen shaking the Macarena I'm
like God I got myself ready for this new
don't make like circle in tomorrow I
just just need to be ready for the
immense celebration we're gonna be doing
if we got this one hit really well but
everything so black and white
Oh God okay
movie TV show both three words third
word third second so three syllables
first syllable win-win air and second
isn't syllable been air Avatar The Last
Airbender first game it was actually
easier than I thought
kids love charades that's yeah it's a
blast it doesn't cost anything you have
to buy anything it's just something you
can do in a circle in a group I always
love games that have an underlying
message so they go away also having fun
and learning something yeah so the fact
that this teaches teamwork and
communication and then losing Delta
important yeah it's like it's just nice
it's not funny
[Music]
you